[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Ryan how are you I'm
okay I know you're congested I'm
congested and it hasn't been covered it
hasn't been fun yeah
um but other sicknesses still exist out
there which is crazy they do you think
whenever you're not feeling well it's
covered but it's not necessary I'm on
the menu I'm way better than I have been
I hope you're not contagious I hope so
as well that would really suck for me I
agree but anyway uh thanks for listening
guys uh we really appreciate the podcast
can survive without you listening if
you're here for Annie Letterman this is
a really great episode it's really
intense
um and I just want to let you know
um look we talk about some sensitive
stuff in this episode there's no doubt
about it uh so if you're sensitive uh to
stories about sexual assault I don't
know if you want to listen but it's it's
really amazing how she opens up and I
think it will help a lot of people and I
just want to say thank you Annie for
opening up so openly I really appreciate
that follow us on our handle social
handles at inside you podcast on
Instagram and Facebook at inside you pod
on Twitter
you can go to the online store the
inside of you online store we've got
tons of great merch uh Smallville
scripts and tumblers and sidey stuff
hats just check it out the inside of you
online store and also if you want to
become a patron the patrons really saved
the show and I couldn't do the show
without them go to patreon.com inside of
you and thank you so much for supporting
this podcast
um
yeah
it's uh
you know my my anxiety is getting a
little bit better lately it's been I've
been a little bit better
you know
um sometimes you just have to give
things a chance you got to give it time
working with this hypnotherapist and it
sounds hokey and weird but it's not it's
about reprogramming your brain so I
listen to something every night before I
go to bed and I listen to the same thing
in the morning when I wake up and it
becomes a habit I've done
15 days in a row now and the more you
listen to it the more your brain starts
to believe it and you can change some
things in your life and that's what I'm
trying so I'll let you know as I
continue this experience but um you know
that along with therapy and
trying to exercise and just trying to
get out of my head man just trying to
get out of my head so I urge you guys if
you're struggling or anything to uh you
know get help and um
you know
that's what I have to say also
sunspin my band our album's coming out
very shortly but also guys please get
tickets to see our show October 1st
Saturday 2 p.m and 6 p.m Pacific
Standard time we're gonna play songs off
the new album our old album some left on
Laurel it's gonna be great we haven't
played in a while go to sunspin.com or
stage it.com and type in sunspin get
tickets uh you can go to the handles I I
show I have links on Twitter and and all
that Instagram I hope you follow me at
the Michael Rosenbaum on Instagram at
the Michael
rosenbum on Twitter
um but thank you
without further Ado let's get inside of
the very funny very talented and very
open and honest sweet
Annie Letterman
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you know I got to tell you I'm
sort of excited to have you I don't get
excited sort of well well I am excited I
am excited to have you here because I
had never met you before and I saw you
on a comedy uh store it was it was a
documentary about The Comedy Store and I
had never seen you before and I watched
this well no I don't know wow thanks for
having me over you piece of [ __ ] no I
watched it and I go who is she I asked
Mike binder I go who is this she's
hilarious did he talk [ __ ] on me no he
said he said you're a wonderful we must
have made up there's times where Michael
Trashman or say nice things really yeah
we got along now is that the comedy
World though that you just you can't
really make good friends with the other
comedians because they all talk [ __ ] on
each other I mean doesn't everyone I
guess Hollywood is the only place where
people don't really talk [ __ ] on each
other publicly because you're all trying
to keep going I guess so I'm learning
get that little cord right there in the
middle that's hovering in there it just
looks where that's better it's fine oh
my God I'm a little anal
I I just want you to look I didn't know
you were gay this is well you know
welcome
I feel safer you know it's funny because
I deal with a lot of anxiety and I just
want to say something funny this morning
I was sitting in my office and I was
like Ryan's like how you doing man I go
ah you know just you know
a little anxious like he looked at me
and he said this he said
well you got your shoes on today you did
it you're dressed
and I was like do I not normally
I think it's a step in the right
direction but also Ryan I don't I don't
think that your your shoes whether
you're I feel like people that are
Barefoot are happy I think there's a
power in being a barefooter I can't I
have to pixelate my feet because of the
wiki for you guys but
it's just you don't get my feet but do
you not have Good Feet no I have Good
Feet I just don't it's just I didn't
know people were jerking off to them so
no I didn't either cover them wait
what's that about yeah don't protect
this is I swear my mother's life Ryan I
don't have anything to finish act like
you don't know about them that is the
most obvious I swear to God are you just
huddled up in your little house pretty
much I just told you I get anxiety and
I'm like yeah that's why you have three
things these are your friends these are
my friends these are my people do you
talk to C-3PO uh not anymore
just relax now you are in a dark place
if you have to tell yourself to relax
and I think look it says relax because I
have another pocket well this podcast I
have another podcast but this podcast is
sort of like we get inside of you it
gets it kind you know I want to find out
get inside are you guys not seeing that
this is weird continuing to be
terrifying relax with my trigger word in
in Middle School in elementary school
when my teachers would tell me to relax
I would go ape [ __ ] why I don't know if
it's my it just made me feel I was like
[ __ ] relax what do you mean relax
[ __ ] you you relax what made me so mad I
threw my glasses case at a teacher once
in fifth grade really Chris Burnett he's
the one of my only good teachers and he
still he comes to my comedy shows when I
go to Philly he's the best were you
always funny
I think I don't know I mean honestly I
was upset when I was a kid I was like an
upset kid well take me back were you
like where did you have good parents
yeah well I have I was twin brother so I
have a twin brother yes I was born
um at midnight July 23 both just had
birthdays right I like that you dropped
it did I give you a happy birthday when
you dropped out it was your birthday I
don't know if you did but I like that
you dropped I like a birthday attention
as well yeah well I didn't know it was
your big birthday though I know it's
it's a scary birthday because it's just
sort of like what what happened yeah you
start to go have I done did you want to
get a sip of water you couldn't decide
I'm a little anal sometimes too it's
just pushing up do you see yeah that's
good but um yeah it's a scary birthday
yeah
he's who's 60 yeah no I'm 50. guys he
just turned 60. he's lying you know how
well then I look fantastic no you're
looking for 50 too really 50 not 52. 50
as well excuse me I'm just kidding no um
but funny funny back when like your
parents I learned well my dad's very
funny I it's like
you know I kind of like closed the
chapter on talking [ __ ] on my parents
parenting skills because it did get me
here but not particularly they're very
like my parents are very liberal very
um like we went to Quaker school and
stuff like that I don't even know what a
Quaker is what is it I know Quaker Oats
yes a Quaker is an oatmeal brand no it's
um
I do like to reach for things you called
that yeah really fast reach it's fine
um my uh
so quakerism is like a form of
Christianity where the belief is that
God is in the form of an inner light so
it's not like a guy outside of yourself
it's something that's inside yourself
that's in everyone so we're pacifists
and
uh that sounds nice isn't it beautiful
are you still a Quaker
quickerish a little bit yeah I mean I
went to a Quakers while I was violently
throwing things at the teacher so you
went to a quaker school what did you
have to wear at Quaker School oh you
just dressed regularly it's not Amish or
anything it's really chill it's a lot of
like there's a lot of like LGBT
there there's a lot of like on we had
like a honestly in my Quaker Meeting
there was just a full Jewish guy are you
serious he would wear his what do you
call this thing
um
um he had the he had yamaka and then he
had his Jew oh uh well the the curls he
didn't have the curls no what is that
called I should know this I'm a Jew
you're you're kind of Jew yeah but I was
very I mean Quaker the Jew part was like
my grandfather my dad's side right so it
was a little bit
disappeared but every time I do 23 may I
get more Jewish I'm like 23 now you keep
doing it it can't be 23 it's like 22
percent
um but your parents were sort of normal
they were my dad worked at University of
Pennsylvania he was in finance he was
the treasurer there and then my mom was
had a bunch of jobs she was went to art
school and then she just had three kids
and kind of got off
I mean got busy she got busy right right
and then
um but she did she worked for this
organization called gray Panthers which
was an organization for in Philadelphia
for the elderly right and fight against
ageism and stuff activism against ageism
and but they took great Panthers which
is now now we know is a little cultural
appropriation
um and the lead the woman who I knew who
was like the founding member you gonna
wear those I punctuate jokes with them
um sunglasses are on folks she uh her
name was Maggie [ __ ] so Maggie [ __ ] yeah
and she stole gray Panthers and were you
uh were you like a troubled kid
well here's what happened so my twin
brother and I I was born breech so my
twin brother was born first so I'm in
utero with uh with a person all squished
up with someone in my mom's stomach and
then I'm born breech so they had to put
me in an incubator for seven days so
that I'm alone so I think a lot of my
troubledness was from just immediately
being alone from being hugged and stuff
well what about like uh like from early
on are we talking young like rebellious
yes doing bad stuff what were you doing
at a young age well when I was a kid kid
I was just
um I had some tactile issues that was a
little Specter me like what does that
mean um like I didn't I cried when
people touched me my socks hurt me
little weird things wow bothered me but
I like to hug my brother you're just an
inquisitive look
he's gonna put his he's gonna put his
[ __ ] on you he's projecting let's take
that note uh socks hurt her socks hurt
me I feel like this is relatable though
they were like there were seams that
would hurt me and stuff
but
um I had I was like lactose intolerant
they didn't know that so I was like
constipated I had [ __ ] issues do you
do are you still lactose intolerant no
you got over that [ __ ] weird
I just I wish I'd get over it I stopped
eating it for forever and then I can eat
it now eggs too I used to be allergic to
and now I'm fine they just make me throw
up throw up and Derek would you get
bloated indigestion all that stuff yeah
I mean it might still do that but it was
I used to get like when I was a kid I
was really severely constipated then as
an older person I would get like
diarrhea well as an older person as an
older human right right but when you're
saying like the young ages where you
were like this how old were you when
your socks hurt like four or five four
or five yeah I was in hell did your
parents think you were kind of a pain in
the ass have you talked to them since
about this yeah they thought I was very
difficult I think well I look at it I
equated to they had boys and boys are
just a little easier to raise right
generally not always but
not the school shooter ones but
maybe they were easy Rays maybe that was
the problem right but um I think I was
like a girl and they weren't used to
having a girl my mom was like very
masculine and I mean she could still
kind of she's a little more feminine now
but she was adopted and then her she was
adopted into a family in Upstate New
York I would say I'm halfway trash
because my dad my mom grew up like in a
wealthy neighborhood and my dad popped
out of a tuna can I
I'm such a piece of trash I love them
but um really he can't it's like and
he's kind of he just I I really remind
my my dad reminds me of me I remind
myself of my dad like we're just so much
alike because I think no matter like
what income level we get to we just
we can't really shake the tuna what is
it what do you do that makes you feel a
little white trashing I see her inside I
just feel and they're hilarious but you
seem like in a good way like a dude in a
lot of ways like I love that thank you
yeah you're just uh like I don't know if
you could use the word chick anymore
Ryan but like a cool chick use all the
words it's okay I'm [ __ ] words up
anyway I still I was about to say
comedian that's okay comedian yeah I
don't do it anymore it doesn't bother me
I don't know about that stuff it used to
bother me when I was first starting
because
I just didn't want to be gendered at all
like I just wanted to be treated fair or
whatever or not sure an iPad my bra I go
for it and what were you yeah I did not
look you looked exactly at but it's
padding so it doesn't count yeah
you didn't look at actual you looked at
a bra I just feel like you're an open
book like I I I just we were watching uh
Comedy Central presents like something
like stories you tell a story a long
story I just retold that story on
Treasures I'm like why am I dragging
these people through it why it's like
pretty outrageous you had sex with your
camp counselor I yeah I banged my camp
counselor after years of having this
crush on him not following him anymore
not knowing what he looked like how many
years later was that
um
14 14 years later yeah it was he wasn't
good looking anymore he just wasn't hot
it wasn't like I'm sure he's had to
other people but to me he just wasn't my
thing but he's still banged him well I
felt guilty because there was that was
the only reason I was at the wedding
I guess I could have said at my period
or something or I could have just said
no I mean I have confidence now I had I
was I was struggling with self-esteem
inside of you is brought to you by
athletic greens Ryan I don't know
what I would do without athletic greens
I have uh I hate taking pills I hate
taking vitamins
a lot of times you're uh they give you
powders that taste crappy that you mix
and you have to hold your nose the way
you drink them and finally
there's a company called athletic greens
that makes something that's actually
delicious to drink easy you do it in the
morning it's got like 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
ingredients probiotics and adaptogens
these are the things that you know
doctors tell me I need to do I need more
of this I need more of that
and for a while I would get all these
pills and I'd forget to take them and I
go are they really working I don't I
feel like I take a glass of this
athletic greens it's so easy in the
morning
and I just feel better you do it for
like it took me like you know within a
week I started noticing my energy levels
were a little better and they got better
and better and I feel like you just feel
like hey I'm doing everything good for
my body
um I think it's really important they
have so many good things
um in this athletic greens and uh you
know
seven thousand five star reviews
recommended by professional athletes
trusted by Leading Health experts
uh it's it's just it's a great great
thing to be doing to your for your body
and I'm gonna have to give you some of
this stuff yeah yeah because I they sent
me stuff and it's good and they also
sent my my buddy Tom Welling who just
loves it he texted me the other day and
welding's you know Welling from my other
podcast talkville and he's just going
off on it he's like man this this stuff
is actually really good it tastes good
too well it's good enough for Tom it's
good enough for me there you go if it's
good enough for Welling we both really
uh enjoy it uh athletic greens is a
climate neutral certified company in
2020 athletic greens purchased carbon
credits that support projects protecting
old growth rainforests it's just a great
company
um they're not only doing good for the
environment in the world they're doing
good for people like us
um whether you eat keto paleo vegan
dairy free or gluten-free
um it's lifestyle friendly athletic
greens contains less than one gram of
sugar no GMOs No nasty chemicals or
artificial anything while still tasting
good it's the one thing with the best
things athletic greens uses some of the
best of the best products based on the
latest science with constant product
iterations and third-party testing it's
just one scoop and a cup of water
every day
that's it
no need for a million different pills or
supplements it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills or supplements
you know I tend especially in late
Mornings in the middle afternoon I get
the brain fog and I just you know I feel
like after taking athletic greens I feel
like I'm just clearer
I could think
easier
um and it just gives me energy it's just
uh I mean you've seen me drink it you
see me Stir It Up it's so quick and easy
it's just like
you know I I put it right next to my
sink so in the morning when I wake up I
just go right there let's do this we're
doing this it's become a habit and it's
a good habit to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you one year
free supply of immune supporting vitamin
D and five free travel packs with your
first purchase
come on all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
i o y again that's athleticgreens.com
i o y get some inside of you is brought
to you by Shopify folks IU Shopify and I
think everyone should use Shopify it's
awesome uh
if you want to sell things uh I've I
started selling one t-shirt or something
years ago on Shopify and now it's turned
into a little bit of a business it's
pretty amazing how Shopify is so easy to
use and they could tell you so many
things about the things you're selling
and they make it simple uh for instance
Shopify will tell you how many items
what items are selling best what items
are selling least how much you made this
month compared to the last month who are
your return customers and on and on it's
pretty fantastic Shopify makes it simple
to sell to anyone from anywhere whether
your thing is vintage tees or recipes
for ghee or start selling with Shopify
and join the platform simplifying
Commerce for millions of your favorite
businesses worldwide with Shopify you'll
create an online store in your Vibe
discover new customers and grow the
following that keeps them coming back
and thanks to 24 7 support and free
libraries full of educational content
shopify's got you every step of the way
it's how every minute new sellers around
the world make their first sale with
Shopify and you will too it's really the
place to go if you have a new business
or you're trying to grow a business uh
Shopify I don't know who else is out
there the Shopify that's all I know is
Shopify and that's all you guys should
know when you're ready to launch your
thing into the spotlight do it with
Shopify the Commerce platform backing
millions of businesses down the street
and around the globe running a
successful business means getting the
insights you need to grow wherever you
are with Shopify single dashboard you'll
manage orders shipping and payments from
anywhere go on try Shopify for free and
start selling everywhere this is
possibility powered by Shopify sign up
for a free trial at shopify.com
inside all over case go to shopify.com
inside to start selling online today
shopify.com inside now a word from our
sponsor betterhelp
better help I don't know what we do
without better help uh you know I have
been lately dealing with a lot of
anxiety and what happens is I hyper
focus on all these negative things Ryan
that keep spiraling and I can't I can't
it's hard to focus it's and it exhausts
me and gives me anxiety
and these thoughts kind of just and I
know it's not I shouldn't be thinking
all these things and I it's like in my
mind I can't put it to rest a lot of
times
and
um
you know it could be tough to to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode and you know especially when you're
facing challenges in life and I know
that therapy helps that talking to
someone and having them talk to you
objectively about what works train
professionals helps it just does I doing
it on my own isn't working it's just not
working
if I don't have someone to talk to I
will just continue to spiral there's no
way out that's how I feel
do you feel that way yeah
um you have to talk to somebody you know
people always say well how'd you get
into therapy it's because I just
couldn't solve these problems on my own
I couldn't you know it's you could say
you're going to do these things and
you're saying oh you what happens is you
just bottle stuff up folks we just
bottle things up until it becomes very
toxic and our body feels it
physiologically we feel the effects of
you know pain depression anxiety and it
takes a toll on your mind and your body
and that is why I got into therapy and
I'll tell you A lot of times I have
nothing to talk about and for the first
five minutes like why am I here what am
I doing and by the end of it I'm like
thank God I'm talking to somebody my
Lord look if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option Ryan here does better help it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists any time
um you know a lot of times people are
selling things and there's ads you have
to read to me this is the easiest read
ever because it's just something I could
talk about forever and
um look better help is is a great place
it's a it's a place to to help a lot of
people when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com inside today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
do you feel like a lot of uh comedians
especially when you're getting started
were you getting hit on left and right
is that something that uh yeah
experiences like non-stop oh they want
to [ __ ] me they're trying to [ __ ] me
they're trying to [ __ ] me yeah and did
you go along with that at all well I
when I first started comedy I got advice
from this guy who doesn't really do
comedy anymore but
he was like don't [ __ ] Comics he's like
when you're first starting like just
don't be the girl that's [ __ ] Comics
which
in a way was good advice but also it's
kind of like what are you gonna wear up
late we're laughing we're having fun or
whatever but I had that in my head so I
did resist it as much as possible right
because you do want to just you don't
want the [ __ ] where you eat yeah in a
lot of ways but I did I hooked up with
and I dated a lot of comics I dated
comedians throughout my career but did
you end up hating them
I don't hang out with them anymore I
mean there's some that when they
approach me I go
just you know
vibrationally is no match anymore it
just was a thing it was but it was nice
when I was there you know it was right
right I you know but I did date I dated
a guy when I was in doing open mics that
was just a horrific person you dated a
guy that you met an open mic yeah when
we were when we were openmakers and how
well how old were you when I was like 25
right six and
he was just not a good guy how so very
mean to my parents very mean mean to
your parents how is one mean to
someone's parents what would one do uh
yell at them
he yelled at my mom he yelled at your
mom how far into the relationship before
he yelled at your mom we did it for like
a year or so it was probably it was
probably eight months in because I
remember I stayed with him but I hated
him I had trouble saying no and I didn't
want to like hurt people's feelings even
though I seemed like a real but uh
um but I really so I just really it was
a self-worth thing and I would just stay
with these people and and just ride it
out
if you just write it out just to see if
it worked trying to fix them do you
think you're trying to fix them I think
I just didn't want to be mean
all right well that's commendable I
guess but kind of it it's not good now I
mean looking back on it but I was
thinking about how I told that camp
story and I
you know I was the one that did the
whole thing I I feel like I I don't
always paint the picture fairly enough
these were just people living their
lives like I crashed the wedding
I attack I like I went after to [ __ ]
this guy I had not seen or know if I had
chemistry with like they were all
innocent really you just went after it I
just went after it you own up to it yeah
it's my fault the whole thing is my
fault and then I go on like TV and I'm
like talking [ __ ] and stuff so you know
it is they got in the Annie storm but
the eye of the Annie storm is it is it
difficult do you think you're easy to uh
to date do you think that's one of my
point dating a comedian well I think it
just has to be the right temperament
um I was very like anxiously attached so
I would get really
kind of like obsessed with people or
like very like clingy or needy or come
up that way sometimes or I just didn't
like the person at all and I just was
kind of like using them as a placeholder
and I think the relationship I'm in now
is like so good because he's so securely
attached he's just like comfortable in
himself he has a crazy mom so he knows
how to
deal with wild women you know do you
talk about him on your in your sets yeah
I do and how does he feel about that he
likes it he likes it he forgives he lets
me do whatever I want he doesn't have
anything even if it's sexual yeah it
doesn't
um
well I don't say like mean I don't have
mean things he's got a small dick my
boyfriend yeah that would be he probably
wouldn't like that but um I don't
I don't like talk [ __ ] on him really I
mean I tease him a little bit he's good
he like he's
he's uh we're having a good life how
long is this you've been dating
um like a couple weeks before the
pandemic we started dating a couple
years
wow is this your longest relationship
[Music]
um
no
no I dated a guy for three years who I
hated the whole time you hate it should
have been and it's again not his fault
it was all on me just hated him full
responsibility he just wasn't that guy
had just like I don't know he just
wasn't evolved and he was looking for me
to be a savior and that wasn't gonna
happen
uh you've done so much before you became
a stand-up comedian so it's baffling how
you kind of fell into it because you you
like
you're a swimmer yeah right you were
like really training to be a swimmer
when I was gonna be yeah I started
training for the Junior Olympics and two
days later I got in a car accident and
quit swimming
and was the driver drunk yeah the drunk
it was a drunk driver it was it was this
uh program at George school I think it
was so I lived in Philadelphia in the
suburbs of Philadelphia and my neighbors
were already doing Junior Olympics and
training in this program so they were
like why don't we we'll take you there
and so I had gone to my initial
consultation and I loved this one
program so you'll go in the morning and
a night at night I mean my life would be
so different if I didn't get in that
[ __ ] car accident because
I just had a lot of
um I was just a creative person and I
had an athletic build I don't know if
you can see the soldiers I was good at
swimming naturally pretty good you're a
really good swimmer obviously I was
pretty good at it yeah eating and like
but I mean I needed to train I was like
raw Italian I wasn't like
you know I I could have gotten really
good did you love it at the time I
couldn't stand it it was so boring but I
didn't get running theme Here you you
date guys you hate them yeah you do
Sports you hate them but now but that
was that was old me and knew me I I
check him I have a meeting with myself
every morning what do I need what do I
want how do I feel and it but it was a
long process to learn that like I would
even matter in my own life like I just
would just kind of get taken places and
so what would the the the accident the
car accident left your foot injured so
you couldn't swim anymore yeah so I
would which would have been a long
training process and I didn't like it
and that was I was 12 about to turn 13
when that happened so I was ready to
start smoking and drinking and that's
when I really started the turn of the
wrong corner right corner for my job now
because you have so much history I loved
it so you started drinking and doing
drugs
12 years old which is crazy looking back
I mean it's insane but I thought it was
so normal what kind of drugs were you
doing I mean I was just smoking weed and
doing like I would do I did like acid
and high school and some pills I took
pills were your parents disappointed
they were just didn't know what to do
they were what I was saying before is
like they were very liberal so they're
very
they're kind to a default where they're
always trying to give people more
chances and stuff and that's something
I've had to unlearn because I definitely
let people stick around too long right
and um
but they yeah they just didn't know what
to do with me and they just gave it was
just there was no real discipline which
looking back they didn't discipline you
helped me be a comedian yeah I know they
didn't discipline no spankings no you're
grounded I got hit like I remember it
like you remember the two hits yeah and
like my parents felt so guilty it's so
funny like just did you deserve it
well sometimes I'm like I could have
gotten slapped around a little but it
wasn't I mean I don't know what I who
knows what I was doing right but I don't
think anyone deserves to get hit so high
school was traumatic high school was
traumatic yes I I had to go to court
take a teacher to court why do you have
to get teachers well we went to my mom
my parents sent me to the school I
wasn't like too bad I was smoking
cigarettes so I was being like a little
bit bad that's 14 13. but then my
parents were like why don't we try out
this check out this other school it was
an alternative school where usually
people would get kicked out and sent
there but my parents like took me there
in the school you didn't have to do
anything you'd have to read you didn't
have to do it I mean you have to do
something it was [ __ ] amazing yeah
and do not read
um sometimes I mean it looks you look
like a reader do I look like a reader I
do mean it that's an insulting way and
so tell by the your expression right now
it's insulting I read history stuff but
I don't you know I'm not a huge reader
not doesn't make you less nerdy but yeah
thank you do you think history helps you
feel more comfortable with what's going
on I just like
um non-fiction except when I'm watching
movies I like horror movies I like
documentaries now I I like nonfiction
too but I listen to self-help stuff does
that really help you yes
I need to do that more it's an amazing
deal with such stuff that just somehow
just caught up with me yeah it just in
life it's like you're going and you're
having fun and you're partying and
you're doing big roles and you're an
actor and you're on magazines and
everything's great and then all of a
sudden something hits you and you're
like who the [ __ ] are you do you know
who you are
I do I'm learning yeah I I was just
saying that but that's how I but but I
am but I answer rhetorical question
thank you for doing anything you should
learn about me
um
the fullest of narcissism you just
answer all rhetorical questions oh you
were asking the universe well she's here
um no I understand that because you're
moving you're busy I feel like I was
that way not necessarily but you know
tumbling through life like crazy things
were happening and then a lot of success
and commenting stuff too and then you're
like
who you know hey you're sad innately sad
about something and you don't know
exactly what it is and you want to
tackle it
I'm not sad anymore though you can you
can tackle it no that's great well you
said you took a teacher to court yeah I
had to take a teacher what did he do
he's like oh you're not sad let me bring
this back up yeah let me bring it here
I'll talk about sex you said I read [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you're sad come back to sadly
um excuse me sorry it was a fright night
sorry fright night
um I
yeah no I my teacher so we went to so
they sent me to the school that was
there was no rules but there was no
rules for [ __ ] anyone there was no
boundaries it was I think I am a product
of a boundaryless childhood and a lot of
like crazy and intense things happen
like I definitely ran for my life more
times than I think most children oh yeah
I had under cars I've screamed for my to
call the cops
I was in weird situations my parents
just were very very trusting and my
boyfriend at school because the way he
was raised was the opposite like his
parents were like do not let anyone [ __ ]
with you blah blah so it's cool to like
kind of see how those two things
manifest and both of us having good
happy careers and
but I just had to do a lot of work and I
I just had to work on not being in like
fight or flight my entire life but the
teacher did not do a good thing he yeah
no he let's say he was my art teacher
and he Jackson pollocked my leg
yeah what the paint was white
what that's a vivid memory that you
cannot this is real it is yeah it was a
white mammal dreads
that's is he in jail no he got um three
years probation
three years probation isn't that
something isn't that something and that
that will stay with you for life you
laugh at it you joke about it probably
still is disturbing well I've had to do
a lot I didn't realize that was staying
with me I would kind of like because
I've always been able to kind of like
joke about things and disassociate but I
was really dragging this man with me I
had I had a realization maybe a couple
years ago where I just I was doing a
meditation
and um in the meditation they have you
like standing on a rock and I would
always go to this rock behind my high
school
like why am I always on this one [ __ ]
Woods like right outside where all this
traumatic and I would anytime there was
like Woods involved I was always
visioning myself there and then they
were like have someone that hurt you
come to you and apologize so my teacher
came to me and apologized I'm like this
was my stuff I'm taking it back it's not
for you and I kind of realized in that
that I had been just dragging this guy
I've been thinking about it talking
about it every day how many years after
20 20 years ago so he got in trouble
back then though he got in trouble when
I was yeah right but you were still
dragging it I was thinking about all the
time I was like I was so like
yeah it just really like
tight and scared I have like job
problems and stuff I work on that jaw
problems jaw problems I have sweaty
armpits hyper hydrants you grind your
teeth and these are all things that was
there all of a sudden this just This
Moment of clarity that this is the cause
of all this how do I get rid of it how
do you get rid of it it's not just that
though because the jaw stuff happened
after my car accident I think that was I
don't know I don't think it was as much
structurally like in my skeleton that
the problem started happening I think it
was more like oh [ __ ] I can't like trust
that I'm gonna get the places I need to
get safely I think it was just sort of
like you didn't trust anyone yeah what
was I I didn't realize until one of my
relationships with one of the people
that I'm scared to see
I'm not scared of him but I'm just it's
just repulsed by him kind of yeah but I
still like love and appreciate him it's
just I I don't there's nothing I want to
talk to him again I'm not like I I used
to really seek his approval we were
friends for a really long time before we
dated right and I would really seek his
approve I don't seek his approval
anymore so there's kind of nothing there
for me right I'm not like excited to go
tell him jokes that I wrote or anything
which is how I used to feel but he
really he helped me in a way by I didn't
realize that like the things that had
happened to me were were not my fault I
kind of had just blamed myself because
that was easier than accepting that all
the people that were kind of in place to
to protect me had let me down that was
like a scarier thing so instead I had
internalized all of it and didn't even
realize I was doing that and and then so
I had a period of time where and
unfortunately I did a lot of podcasts
during that time where I was really mad
at my parents like really you felt like
they were at fault I was so [ __ ] like
where the [ __ ] were you I mean even like
down to my teacher who I took to court
his
lawyer was my softball coach like
everyone involved was someone that was
supposed to protect me and it just felt
I just had to learn the lesson where and
you let them continue along without
saying what the [ __ ] I didn't even
realize it was that I mean I felt like
it was bad but I just didn't even you
know my it took me a long time even
though I've non-stop talked and I've
been talking for a living it took me a
long time to really learn to like
appropriately speak up for myself and
just take care of myself but I'm doing
good now and I really feel like
um I usually don't talk about this story
again this is it it feels fine to talk
about it now but sometimes I like I
don't want to not that it's like I don't
want to talk about it but it's like yeah
I don't have to say it anymore it's kind
of like already out there and the juju
EMDR I never did that I never did that I
did I did it's the most emotional stuff
DMT you did DMT well emdr's with the the
eyes that's cool yeah how crazy is that
it really worked it was it was so
surprising I was hysterical and I don't
I didn't know why I mean I knew why
after it all happened were you molested
no but um well I had I had a uh a moment
where I escaped it yeah I was about to
get molested and I got away how old were
you I was probably 12. was it a director
it was this guy named Les who lived up
in the Catskill it's like don't be so
hacky less yeah don't be a child unless
her name less his name was less I swear
to God I wrote about it his name was Les
and he worked at the um the Bungalow
Colony yeah and he used to always help
me catch uh
salamanders
and like oh Michael come here and then
one night he was just like hey you
should come to the casino because
there's a casino it's not a casino with
like for older people like you know
video games and pizza and it was right
there in the Bungalow colony and he he
said yeah come on I'll get you some
pizza we'll play some video games and my
grandparents after me begging and
screaming they said yeah I go it's less
and they said sure and I went and then
he goes hey you want to see where I live
and I said sure and he lived right
behind the Bungalow you want to see my
salamander yes Jesus you went right we
went right down the stairs behind the
Bungalow building behind the casino and
he opened up the garage door he lived in
the garage that's where he lived and he
says oh you see back here yeah it's my
couch and my bed's back there and closed
it so scary and we went back there and I
started I was I was like this is less he
couldn't hurt me yeah because this is
how you are as a kid you're trusting
yeah and then you know cool ice cream
thanks yeah man you're awesome Les and
then he said take a look at this and it
was a magazine of naked men
and I got my heart started beating
really fast you got a little horny no
didn't get horny petrified that's a good
way to know I got up and you know when
you're you can't run fast it's just like
your molasses it's just like and I got
to the garage door and I was I couldn't
get it open I was shaking I was like
like that and he ran up he goes hey hey
and he screamed at me and he came up to
me he put his hand on my shoulder and he
looked at me goes I'm Gonna Let You Go
it's okay I'm gonna let you out here
and he opened the door and he let me go
did you tell people or did you keep it a
secret I I was so embarrassed by it even
as a 12 year old that I didn't want to
share it with anybody that I remember I
was supposed to be home in an hour and I
hid behind a tree for like 45 minutes to
just get my bearings somehow at 12 years
old I still knew that I got to get my
[ __ ] together I got to compose myself
before I go back I can't let them know
that something happened I can't because
somehow it was my fault in a way I I
don't know what it was like you know
well you're yeah because you were like
excited about it too it's like there's
like the Betrayal of being oh my God it
was terrifying I couldn't get away from
that Catskill Mountains fast enough yeah
it was it was terrifying but I I
survived was it like Dirty Dancing type
Place uh sort of yeah and that was just
sure like vacation you would go on yeah
my grandparents thank God they took me
there for the Summers thank God no it
was the end of the summer and I just
remember like you know I I did I forgot
it I blacked it out yeah which I'm sure
is that amazing your brain can [ __ ]
do that it just said no we don't
remember that
and it wasn't until many many years
later I got really guilty and I thought
God if I turned him in because he
probably molested kids he probably did
it to someone else and I took fault I
felt horrible I was just a kid so
obviously I didn't know but it was just
oh I still every once in a while ago oh
my God that happened yeah well like you
do with your story yeah well there's a
horror and because I did go to court
there's a horror in that too I mean I
really got treated like [ __ ] [ __ ] I
had to learn that lesson and I didn't
really learn it until I couldn't
understand it felt so unfair because I
was like all people told me to do when I
was a kid is tell the truth but then
here I am and I always tell the truth I
do not lie you know I get that from you
I just it's like my high authenticity
and honesty I see it
um and then comedy which I wish I could
flip so I could make my comedy a little
bit funnier and just lie a little uh no
I have some jokes that are made up but
um but you know to learn that like what
telling nobody wants you to tell the
truth because it's [ __ ] sucks the
truth is like hard for everyone's like
all right now we gotta put on our suits
and go to court we gotta do this they
were calling you a liar probably didn't
they yeah which really pissed me off
because I was like I really like have
like Asperger's you don't lie type thing
did they start talking about your
drinking or you're smoking well um I
think I think that's actually
what
um why that school was such a bad
situation because if you think about it
the kids that are troubled like that are
the easiest ones to molest because
they're already not credible you know
it's already like oh they're troubled or
whatever so it makes sense and then that
teacher that did that to me I always
thought it was just him and then I found
out all these other teachers in the
school what I know and the school's
still kicking and I had to do it when I
started getting really mad at my parents
yeah you know a couple years ago
um they I went home and I saw that they
had been donating to the high school and
I was like you lost I was so pissed and
I understand that they have to protect
themselves there in the evening of life
like for them to like open all of this
up and they listened to me and they
apologized and we got to get through do
they cry
a little bit but I don't want them to
feel bad now I don't I really do believe
that even though I don't want to like
let anyone off the hook for anything but
I do feel like they did do what they
thought was right at the time like they
didn't know whatever denial or whatever
was going on they just didn't they would
never do that now you know you know
that's what I went through too when I
did that EMDR that it was you do this
thing over and over and then close your
eyes and think of this moment think of
this moment and by the end
I was like tears coming down my face
couldn't believe that I was so
hysterical couldn't believe that I'd
opened up like this could not understand
the last thing I remember saying is just
well what do you feel now and I just go
and it was unsolicited I go
I forgive them yeah they didn't they
didn't know better
they did the best they could and it
sucked and it was but that's all they
knew and it was like holy [ __ ] that hurt
the most yeah just being able to go
because it was always like [ __ ] them
[ __ ] you you guys were this you guys
were that and when you can just
eventually just go
you know what
you did your best yeah it sucked
I I got yeah some bad [ __ ] happened to
me but it wasn't your fault yeah and
then we it taught us lessons you know I
feel like I got to learn things like
very young which maybe were hard but I
always look at it like I had to be an
adult when I was a kid so now I get to
be a kid when I'm adult like I get to
really I've been through some [ __ ] like
yeah I'm like I'm good to go I learned a
lot of lessons and also with my mom I
really this really like was kind of the
piece that that finished the puzzle for
me but my mom went to a all girls
boarding school and she called me a
couple years ago and she was like oh my
God you're never gonna believe what
happened there was this teacher that
lived on campus and all the cool girls
got invited to go to his house and have
dinner and sleep over and I never got to
go
she goes I just found out he was
molesting them now my situation was my
teacher and his wife that they were both
my teachers they
um had us sleeping had me and one of my
friends sleeping over there all the time
and so I was like how do my parents like
let this happen but in my mom's head she
was giving me like letting me be like
the cool kid it was like her own which
is so naive and like I'm sure she feels
like an idiot for that but she just
didn't
she thought she was like being nice
right right yeah you know she's trying
to help you in my mind and so when I
have kids if I have kids I do think I
probably will have kids I got some
frozen embryos but um it'd be kind of
rude to defrost but we'll see
um you know I I'm gonna be such a better
parent from all of the knowledge that I
have you know and I think that people
can be better parents now too just
because of how much access people have
to educational sources and resources wow
I appreciate you opening up like this
this is like I know you normally you're
just going on Comedy and it's all funny
and so but like this helps people yeah
believe it or not this you know somebody
out is out there listening going hey you
know she's faced all this adversity she
went through this [ __ ] and yeah you look
at you now you know what help me with my
mom too what she probably kill me for
saying this but I just realized my mom
is just like a person and she was just
all day
she was like reading romance novels and
taking like my mom was just masturbating
all day
she was just busy flicking the bean and
I'm like now that I like I'm like my mom
was just a woman masturbating
she had her hands she was busy good for
her she was just trying to find her own
pleasure speaking of the Dolphins you
were a dolphin trainer uh right I did I
did the hell did you jump in a dolphin
train okay so I graduated early believe
it or not that school decided to let me
graduate early because you were smart
well I was smart and I also was in court
I was a problem
she's about to find out about the rest
of us that are molesting everyone right
right I mean they couldn't believe it
that I was told on everyone that was so
weird were you ostracized sort of for
everybody that the people look down at
you you other schoolmates oh yeah [ __ ]
them liar piece of [ __ ] people um hawked
loogies on my door handle people and
even just to the point of like oh my God
years later it was like there was a lot
of like kids that were it was like kids
with special needs a lot of times like a
lot of learning disabilities and stuff
and then bad kids so it was like this
mixture of like the fringes on both
sides it was the bullied and the bullies
that's why I'm a little bit in between
but
um
yeah so you graduated early I graduated
early but years later I saw one of the
like the nerdy kids like the weirdo kids
he used to like put deflated balloons in
his hair he was just this little he was
really cool like little artists yeah he
tied them into his hair my school was
like filled with freaks but um so he
um I saw him years later he was a nice
kid you know and he even said to me he's
like you made that stuff up about
our teacher right I'm like what
like why would and he was so upset that
like he had upset me it didn't even
occur to him because he just believed
what everyone was saying yeah and but
that's been a lesson in my life too to
not need to defend myself I don't I know
what's true I don't need everyone to
believe me it's like even though it's
frustrating but yeah
um but whatever and anyway what were we
talking about I graduated earlier so I
graduated early and I did I had a year
off so my parents had like set aside
money for this this school which
shockingly charged a lot of money to
molesters uh how do we well with the
parents too
um so
um they had set this the money aside I
graduated when I was 16 so they'd set
the money aside
and um so I used that money I did a
program in Central America you're
helping kids yeah it was fun yeah and
then I became like I got into the
special ed field I was doing I was a
special ed camp counselor I mean you
have a heart of gold though see this is
why you would be a great mom I do I do
you have patience somehow don't you yeah
you make the most out of the difference
well I try to I I can get caught up I
can start to get really like tense I
have a new mantra where everything is
easy and fun everything is easy and fun
I have to remind myself do you say that
to yourself everything's easy and fun
everything I have to because I get
really I can wind myself real tight how
does that work just saying that I do
hypnosis I I had like hypnosis is the
number one thing I have ever done in my
life I've been in therapy since I was a
kid it's better to me than talk therapy
than any then who hypnotizes you
um my heaven says his name Mary Lou
Rodriguez and she I actually learned
I've taken her course twice on how to
become a hypnotist I just don't really
know what I'm gonna do with it yet you
could hypnotize me I mean I could good I
would wanna I would wanna take a couple
more classes I want to get really good
at it I don't want to like halfway well
it's not it's really simple because your
brain won't do anything your
subconscious will not do anything that
it wouldn't do like you can't I couldn't
make you go murder someone unless you
are someone that deep down wants to
murder people
Lex Luthor well it's so weirdly of hair
does that make you feel good that you
played a bald guy so now you like I
guess like I have lots of hair now so
it's like yeah was that embarrassing to
be bald man for a while I felt like uh
girls that like me were usually goth and
like golf girls are hot listen to The
Cure
they love what they love [ __ ] oh yeah
[ __ ] yeah wow
um it was fine it was you know it was a
time in my life but uh but like do you
recommend someone like me to go to
hypnotism I think you would I think it
would help you so much because your
anxiety is a habit it's a habit it's a
habit it's not you're not an anxious
person you're a person with anxiety
you can be like anything so it's like
you just have these habits I have them
too I spin I spend like I just decided I
have to stop smoking weed for a while
because maybe forever I don't like to
say forever because that's hard but um
because it's it feeds that anxiety that
spin so I'll wake up in the morning just
spin spin spinning and then I have these
tools to get out of them I know what I I
listen to hypnosis and I can get out of
it but I don't want to wake up with that
that means my whole sleep has been like
you know my subconscious is still
spinning I had anxiety when the first 10
minutes of this podcast I'm not kidding
I was like I broke it I don't know I
started listening I started being in the
moment and I started just going stop it
what are you doing I was just like I
don't know I just my I got numb I got
kind of got a little flush it just
happened sometimes it happens I have an
effect on people yeah there you go but
but hypnotism could really help me it
could it could you've seen it work I
swear I swear by it and I just got my
dad's name 100 I'll rewind it she'll no
I'll give it I'll give you her number
okay she'd love should love to work with
you I'm sure but she's so she's um
so what do you do it's like hypnotherapy
is the session is we do it over Zoom
obviously I don't want to do in Zoom
well she lives she lives in um Portland
okay you can fly out there if you want
it really works over Zoom yeah
so you you have your you have your
um your session and it's like what are
your blocks in life what are you looking
for in your life so for me if it's like
I'm having trouble writing jokes what is
it you get to the bottom of like what is
that right what is the like underlying
belief that you have that is keeping you
from writing jokes what you know and so
I'm not good enough I'm not right of
course people are gonna know that I'm
not yeah that I'm a fraud or whatever
and you get to whatever that basic thing
is and then you figure out what your
brain needs to hear to get through that
block
and then she creates a hypnosis for you
out of that and then you just listen to
it in the morning and in the night in
the evening and you swear by this I
swear by it my dad my dad resisted it
it's hard because I like lived in my car
and I was kind of like a [ __ ] up
quote-unquote I don't identify as that
anymore but
um so it's hard when I when I recommend
it to certain people that have known me
through those stages because I'm still
kind of car living in your car Annie so
my dad's like all right [ __ ] yeah
hypnosis whatever I'm like that I swear
and I finally just bought him the
sessions I was like because my dad is
like 81 and he's still struggling to get
his taxes done he has so much he's put
so much anxiety into his taxes for some
reason like his whole life's worth has
gone into getting his taxes done by
himself without help from an accountant
I don't know what it is it's just all of
his anxiety and self-worth has been
wrapped up in taxes and I know that a
lot that is like a trigger for a lot of
people you have a business manager right
I do oh yeah I just give it away
sometime I don't like you just give it
away but he feels like
as a man that's had to take care of his
family and all this stuff it's just all
tied into it and I finally got him with
her and he's starting to do this he
likes it he loves it he's like oh my god
wow lion well it's like this could be it
yeah this could be it it's not just
reprogramming it's so cool
I'm excited about this it's amazing I
thought you know I was having I was
playing tennis last night are you good
at tennis I'm okay I play High School
tennis I'll play with you anytime great
um but I was having this conversation
with a friend and she was like
um
just tell me all these things like CBD
really works and this and that but she
said she had some guy who comes over the
house stands like four feet away from
her and does this energy thing and she
says it changed her life and I'm like do
you believe in that stuff that kind of
energy in there to an energy worker
where she like kind of massages parts of
your body it was helpful to me it was um
it was really cool it's like up in
Topanga Canyon it's like she has a cool
spot and she's really she felt
comfortable she's a yeah she's like a
really beautiful bohemian yeah she's
like a like a light she's a real sweetie
but um I really liked that I haven't
gone to her in a while though but it
really did help me um I always see
actors there too
it's good yeah but it just she just like
where are you holding your your trauma
in your body and like learning to
release it she gave me some tools that I
never use but you know what's funny is
you know
judging a book by its cover I'm I I
wasn't judging you you can just all I
know I met you yeah no I met you at
Bobby Lee's party I'm friends with Bobby
like you we love them and we met briefly
but I saw the comedy special before I
was like Lyle you gotta introduce me to
her she's hilarious and it was brief but
then I watched a lot of your stuff and
I'm like you know the way you talk and
you're you're stick and it's funny and
it's dark and it's this and I'm like you
don't think someone like you would have
their [ __ ] so together and you really
sound together I'm working on it it's
amazing I mean you're in a healthy
relationship you do the hypnotism you
you just you're trying new [ __ ] you tell
these mantras or whatever to yourself
and
it's it's uh what's the word it's uh I'm
optimistic uh here what's the word it's
it's uh
inspiring inspiring there's the word
it's inspiring so why out of all this
what made you want to do stand-up comedy
um stand up was just my like way out of
trouble I just was able to be funny like
I just I don't know how funny I was as a
kid but as a like from 12 on honestly
once the trauma hit I got pretty [ __ ]
funny that just was my way to do things
and my dad's funny I've always been
trying to impress him it was just
something I was like I think I can
[ __ ] do this I just like I've just
always been kind of wild and I was I
would say people found me to be a
problem until they until I was able to
like
harness it into my artwork you know and
I like to draw I'm an artist I like to
do you know like I've always kind of
been art oriented and um but I just I
just figured out I just figured it out
when I was 25 I quit drinking I moved to
New York to do comedy you said that you
you said that you would when you got you
got so drunk you'd black out you said
alcoholism wasn't fun alcoholism wasn't
fun it was more like you were taking a
break like yeah it was like a break from
your mind oh yes that was one of my old
jokes that was a good one it was like a
smoker but you were serious yeah I hated
myself I had so much repressed shame and
like anger around all the things that
had happened to me and I just hadn't
processed it so I would just drink and
because I just I it just it manifested
in like self-hatred I just thought I was
bad I just had this you don't want to
live no I wanted to live that's the
thing that was what was weird I've never
been suicidal or anything like that you
never got to worry about me really never
I will never it's amazing how you could
hate yourself but want to live yeah it
was like this I still wonder if Adolf
Hitler was that guy and that's when I
killed the Jews
um that's it well she's 23 Jewish yeah
guys it's okay she's totally cool
um and each 23 man yeah makes me more
okay 23 me her it's really fun but I
keep getting chewier I wish I'd had at
the beginning of my career
um would have helped but yeah no it's um
I I think that like
that maybe subconsciously like the true
belief I had was that I was good you
know but that belief right above it was
that I was a piece of [ __ ] you know and
so I just wanted to drink to get away
from myself I didn't like saying no to
people so if I got drunk I kind of like
didn't have to be responsible for
for you know anything like that and
and then I quit drinking and started to
accommodate it was just like this is
what I'm supposed to be do you remember
the day you quit drinking yeah what day
was it January 28th
um I think it was a Wednesday it was
2009 might have been the 29th but it was
the day or it was after Wednesday I
think that Mike was either on a Tuesday
or Wednesday I didn't my first open mic
and I quit drinking the day after
what was the first open mic like
um well I had already gone in deciding
that this was going to be my career
I was like based on nothing I just I
just want this is a this is my thing I
just knew it was my thing I used to have
like my professors in college would my
teachers in high school would jerk off
at me and then my professors in college
would always be like you're so funny but
I would they would I would like annoy
people in class and they're like just do
stand up like I used to have teachers be
like just do stand up you're supposed to
be doing stand-up because I'd just be
doing jokes because you're always
commenting on life as you as you live it
well I actually I was hanging out with I
have a uh one of my I have a couple
shamans but one of my shamans is my
Ayahuasca Shaman have you you've done
Ayahuasca I've never done it I did it
six times is it worth doing it was
excellent but it should be something
that you really want to do it's like you
don't have to do it it's not something
like you're you know it's not gonna
change my life it will change your life
but you can do other things that will
change your life too like hypnotism like
hypnotism and subconscious program it's
not it's not for everyone but I had a
really amazing
um an amazing experience doing and I
really like I have this Shaman who's
this um like beautiful like
like uh he's just such a good guy he's
just such a sweet man he's from um South
Africa calms you he's just a cool I just
yeah I just he's just a wise sweet
centered guy and I just I met him
randomly at The Comedy Store he was a uh
in the audience visiting to do a
ceremony and um
he one of the guys that worked at The
Comedy Store was like and I'd had like
I'd gone on a bad date
um
and where I was like dating this guy and
he like introduced me to all his friends
and then the same night was like you
know I'm still seeing other people I'm
like what are these mixed message like I
was just so pissed like why am I bowling
with your friends then [ __ ] uh like
what the [ __ ] I'm like also and I'm
seeing other people you don't tell
people that it's [ __ ] rude in the
beginning [ __ ] cool you're [ __ ]
one of my friends probably awesome but
um so I was on stage like so like in
such a sour mood and got off stage and
there was just this guy and this woman
and they just were like I don't even
know they were just shiny people they
were just like something going on so I
like high five them like oh and then
later it was right after
um my friend Brodie Stevens had I don't
know did you know Brody uh I know yeah
Brody had um himself had offed himself
or recently so it was like a weird it
was just such a heavy time because it
was you know we just spent kind of every
day with him
and so
um The Comedy star I would always like
kind of like hang out late with him
and he had died like a couple weeks
before
and uh maybe a month before and
so I was like staying late and smoking
cigarettes I was being very like
self-sabotaging and I was like why am I
still here tonight like why can't I
leave this [ __ ] place and then I go
into the office and one of the guys that
worked there was like oh my God my
friend wanted to meet you I didn't know
you were still here
and I was like who he's like you
high-fived him I was like who the [ __ ]
is that guy
and he's like he's a breath work
instructor and I was like oh I love
breath work I want to do breath work and
he's like all right he's an Ayahuasca
Shaman and I was like what
and I was like I want to do Ayahuasca
and he was just telling me he was like
he he told me that the guy wanted to
meet me that he had come to a bunch of
the shows and this was when I was really
not I had no real name for myself I'd
done a couple things maybe but I was
going on really late in the lineup there
was like not that many people there
um but he had said that the the this man
I don't say his name because yeah it's
fine but he was that I was his favorite
comedian I was like oh he's probably
trying to bang me and he's like he's gay
don't worry you're safe he actually just
likes you and I was like oh
um so it was cool it was like nice that
he like kind of could see what I was
what I was about even when I was in this
kind of like angry right and so um they
had had someone just dropped out people
would come from all over the United
States to come do it and all over the
world there were people who came in from
England and different places to come do
this ceremony with him they're like 20
people
and someone had just dropped out so I
canceled my spots and usually you're
supposed to like go on a special special
diet beforehand and stuff but I just
bought a bucket and drove to
San Diego and they had like this bought
a bucket because you puke yeah you bring
a bucket right we're throwing up and it
was good it was really important for me
to do it right around I got to really
kind of purge a lot of the
the guilt that kind of came with Brody
dying like a lot of that stuff and a lot
of my issues with even with that guy and
stuff so it was really cool it was it
felt like 30 years of therapy and and
two nights right and it was really cool
but he um he came into town recently and
um I didn't actually I was doing
stand-up but he was there for an extra
day so I didn't do Ayahuasca with him
but he led a ceremony and we ended up
just a couple of us went to
um up in the mountains and rented a
house and we just hung out and did San
Pedro
and it was really cool but we were
watching the sunset over the mountains
and I was turned watching them like they
were watching it and I was like I just
liked watching them enjoy the sunset and
I was like this is so me like this is
like my life I just like I don't know I
just really wanted to see them enjoying
it more than just like seeing it story
in my life too it's making people happy
yeah other people to be happy makes you
happy which I don't know you know it's
like a balance of whether it's good or
bad you know yeah
um how do you deal with uh do you do you
still bomb
um you know what's so funny okay so I
tape on my sets now so I can make clips
for online and
um
so now I can see whether when I'm
thinking I'm bombing so the comedy show
was hot as [ __ ] [ __ ] the other night
and I started sweating so that's a
symptom of bombing when I feel a symptom
of bombing my brain just goes into your
bombing and I'm going into survival it's
just sort of like oh it's like not joy
and happiness and fun like all of a
sudden it switches from I had a moment
in my career was actually after going to
a Papa Roach concert but uh backstage
um that I shifted where I realized like
I was going out there needing the
audience to give me something rather
than going out to like serve the
audience and once I did that so I think
once I start bombing I go into like
fight or flight and then I'm like more
needy from the audience but I wasn't my
boyfriend was like filming he's like you
[ __ ] killed
and I was like it's probably just one
moment that you felt didn't work as well
or it's just I like honestly it's like
my brain when I start to like when I
started sweating I was like like I just
wasn't even like hearing things as
loudly you were nervous yeah nervous I
just wasn't like isn't that terrifying
no
let me just you just ride the wave
I love doing com I don't know like I
love it when it's good or bad I just
love doing it it's so fun it's like the
best thing it's so cool do you want your
own show like TV show yeah uh maybe
Annie Lederman show it's Letterman I
know I'm a natural leader Letterman
sorry Letterman as a leader it happens a
lot Letterman no I know it's not but do
you do you um
close to it yeah I did well I wrote this
horror movie with my with Bonnie
McFarland who's like my friend slash
hero I always looked up to her like
she's one of the best comedians ever I'm
always like I don't want to make it
sound like I look up to her like
it's just she's just my girl I just
[ __ ] love her we've just both like
try to be funny as much as [ __ ]
possible it's just so fun to talk to her
but um we wrote a horror movie that I
will be starting oh yes we just finished
the script what's it called Dead Inside
wow yeah
visit horror horror scary or
psychological it's more like comedy
horror you'll probably get annoyed by it
no it would probably pursue why because
you said nope I didn't want it to be too
funny well you'll want you would want it
to be more horror like I know the
the different genres but um we'll see
it's like it's got some twists that I
can't really talk about but we'll see I
mean it's exciting it's really exciting
it's a new chapter yeah it's exciting so
I want to do more of that I don't like
um
I'm not so drawn to acting unless it
feels like a part that I would have
written yeah I just don't I don't have
that like
desire to
like play other people that much so do
you want to just maybe I would maybe I
would if it was the right part I don't
know you just want to do specials and
have your have your your podcast trash
Tuesday your podcast yeah and then I
have my and then I also have a I have a
Spotify show every Monday night that's
live that's been so fun I just haven't
where can they go just Andy Letterman on
Spotify
um if you go to Spotify live I also
posted all the links on my podcast every
Monday right and your Instagram handle
as well is Annie Letterman Annie
Letterman
but that's like it's called Don't bore
me so that's my fans get to it's an
audio show where they get pulled up by
my producer and they try to impress me
and then they either get booted or get
to finish their story it's pretty fun I
like it I like it yeah that's every
Monday at five
um PM PST this is called uh [ __ ] talking
with Annie Letterman
um these are my patrons they are my
favorite cheers and these are folks that
are loyal if they like you and they
they're gonna like you because you're
you've talked real you've kept it real I
keep it real [ __ ] except for me
seriously these are fake are they well
they're padded I don't believe in
getting I don't think you need to get
any work
not that people get work done if you
want but I for myself I'm like you can
do with makeup and socks you can do make
miracles happen
and then you have to do it all the time
you could just go back to your regular
boobs the next day it's so fun makeup
and socks
I'm telling you I I was thinking about
that I think on Tick Tock I'm going to
start doing courses on how to just give
yourself fake body parts good for you
for the day uh these are rapid fire
Leanne says what's off limits in comedy
and I have a feeling I know the answer
to this absolutely nothing however
you got to deal with the consequences if
you're [ __ ] piss off of a group of
people
sure but nothing's off limits It's just
sometimes people don't Michelle K I'm
gonna add to this question all-time
favorite comedian and also other
favorite comedians okay I have um Bonnie
McFarland who I just mentioned so funny
one of the finest people I watched her
we were in
um in Texas together and I cried after
her set it was so good wow I was just
like I'm so glad you're my friend
um Dave Attell
um still love Louie you can't I mean the
[ __ ] can't stop being so [ __ ]
funny
um
who else
uh do you feel like you've lost any
respect for him are you kind of like hey
that was a chapter in your life well
that
even deal with that because you guys
which is such a weird well
I mean like I've opened for him since
all that went down he did not try to
[ __ ] me
rude Louie um no it's gross
I wish I didn't know any of that
don't you wish you could just be not
woke you're like I want to be not woke
yeah it's like you're such a great guy I
didn't know but I don't know I don't you
know I just I guess I look at that
as a mistake and for me well
I think the thing everyone gets mad
about is maybe the way he sounds very
arrogant the way he like wrote the
apology but I he wrote things in the
apology that made me like unders like
articulated things I felt before that I
never he said something about like where
he's like when I thought I was
presenting them with a question I was
actually presenting them with a
predicament
and that is how I felt a lot of times
so I don't know it's just right other
comedians
um
I mean there's so much old school old
school
Carol Burnett
I mean I love Joan Rivers
she was kind of old school she just
croaked I was watching her special I
will say this like as I'm sort of like
in hypnosis I'm sort of like creating
what like what do I want to be right
like where do I want to go and I am
sorry to say this guys I am going to
Lady Gaga this [ __ ] sorry [ __ ] I'm
going big
um but
um I do like I've been watching all
these documentaries of like powerful
women not just women powerful men and
people that have inspired me throughout
my life
and she was so unhappy when I watched
Joan Rivers documentary it made me so
sad she was so seeking the approval of
like the outside world when it was like
she did have it it's just she was only
looking at the people that weren't
giving it to her right and so for me
like I take from her
like the part from her that I'm taking
when I'm creating the like you know
future Annie
Rising risen star
um I take from her that she was always
funny yeah she was I mean I wasn't I'm
move very serious on the spot guys but
but you know she just always took she
always went for the joke and I just love
that she's always being funny uh Kelly
asked how do you handle hecklers best
type of story you do I mean don't do it
on on purpose don't do it to other
people and if you do it it's like
there's a boundary of it but I like love
doing crowd work so I'm like [ __ ]
bring it it's annoying if someone's
interrupted if someone's drunk someone
interrupts the middle of a joke it's
like [ __ ] I'm like in the middle of this
but sometimes I just have to like break
the fourth one be like I got 80d [ __ ] I
can't handle this like this isn't gonna
work for all of us if you keep doing
this I try my best to not get people
kicked out like I wait as long as I
possibly can
if they're really disrupting the show
they'll go but sometimes the show just
becomes about them and hopefully the
audience funny enough for the audience
that they're not like feel like but you
don't get intimidated you don't get
you're like let's go
you can't I don't think you should ever
be mad on stage if you show like anger
or fear or something it's like because
it's a it's a you're in a position of
power these people are trusting you to
be in to control the control of the
audience for but I had um I had a guy
who I'll tell you two Heckler stories
this was the worst one I was at The
Comedy Store this guy had been heckling
the comedian before me and it was
[ __ ] pissing me off I was [ __ ] mad
I was [ __ ] hyper Vigilant like I'm
gonna [ __ ] this guy up so I went on
already pissed and um he was this like
British guy this older British guy was
wasted
and um it was Halloween and I just did
kind of like a hacky Your mom joke where
I just went on it's so weird like that
you're here you know because I've been
planning my costume I was gonna go as
your mom for Halloween but I really
couldn't fit I couldn't fit all the
dicks in my mouth it just wasn't big
enough and the man got so mad it was
hilarious he got so pissed so then he
stands up he's like don't talk about my
and I'm cocky thinking security is
around but this was back in the day when
The Comedy Store was not what it was
what it is now it had a little lapse in
uh security for a second but I thought I
was good so I'm talking so much [ __ ] to
this guy he stands up because don't ever
talk about my mom I go oh my God I
didn't realize your mom was like that
big of a [ __ ] that you thought I would
actually know her like I don't even I'm
not even from your country right like
I'm not doubling down [ __ ] yeah so then
he starts to charge the mound like he's
coming at me and I'm like uh security
security and they got him someone got
him right before he got on the stage but
it was like I almost got [ __ ]
big time but it would have been even
though I don't want to get hit it would
have been a very funny joke afterwards
that's another thing that's great about
being a comedian any moment of
discomfort discomfort becomes something
great right
um and then
um a fun one was I was in St Louis and
the club that I was at did not have
um food so people were in Full Black Ops
I mean they were wasted but so I
anticipated the second night so I had
um the guy that was like working on my
rider and stuff he went I had him I go I
have an addition to my rider I need two
loaves of bread so he brought me bread
and butter and so this girl kept
heckling and I shoved bread in her mouth
yeah I was like all right you're in
trouble now open your mouth because she
was wasted were people dying it was the
funniest thing in the world and then I
was just like throwing I was like who's
hungry I was just throwing pieces of
bread out to everyone like frisbees it
was great I have footage of it I got to
cut it off you have to cut them it was
great uh so you got trash Tuesday you've
got this Spotify thing you do every
Monday every Monday and then I am coming
out with my solo podcast anniewood I
used that one called me inspiration but
I'm trying to Rebrand so it's not as
mean negative even though I've been kind
of mean recently but sorry do you always
have something to say do you you never
worry about not having enough to say
yeah I don't I mean I have like my voice
sounds damaged right no I don't think it
sounds damage it's not from cigarettes
it's from talking you don't smoke
anymore either do you no I don't smoke
cigarettes I got hypnotized I literally
can't and this is how I know it works
Jesus right after I got hypnotized I was
performing at the Life is Beautiful
Festival in
um Las Vegas we were at
it was like green day we were at Green
Day we saw Ludacris it was so fun it was
like Modest Mouse it was just such a fun
[ __ ] time
um I have my friends there with me they
had camel crushes my favorite cigarette
pop at a festival camel crushes with all
my friends couldn't smoke like it's not
in my identity to smoke anymore couldn't
smoke cigarettes can still smoke weed
still smoke weed but I'm I'm gonna get
rid of that one next this has been great
this is of course I had no fear I did
well that's good I think you should have
fear you don't know me yeah I just
didn't know I was like yeah I hope she
likes to talk I hope she's got some
stories I hope she's got some but you
had like it's kind of inspirational like
when you're doing your [ __ ] man you went
through a traumatic childhood and look
at you now yeah you're doing it and I
like it's fun to do comment and kind of
laugh about all these things I get a lot
of my fans my meet and greets are people
coming to tell me [ __ ] that happened to
them and how I'm helping them get
through it so that is like not to sound
whatever but it does make it kind of
worth getting jerked off on by my
teacher as a child
do you get through getting jerked off do
you feel like you're hard in other
Comics or do you want to see other
Comics succeed or do you feel like
because you know that whole Green Room
mentality people are really tough on
each other you're like oh she's not
funny he's not funny do you think you're
kind of tough to do other people are you
do you go up and say hey really funny
set that was great do you do that or do
you stick around if it I don't usually
stick around because I'm it's just I
just have done it every night of my life
so I just I'm in and out it's more like
self-preservation getting in and out of
the club right because I will if I stay
I [ __ ] am there until [ __ ] three
in the morning I mean it's crazy how
late I can stay at the grocery store but
um yeah if I see someone sat and I like
it of course I would tell them yeah
and um I would never tell I mean it's
like
I did get anything recently where I like
I called someone unfunny but I didn't
say their name and then they released
that it was their name and I felt bad
then I was like oh I wasn't trying to
call like a specific person on funny I
was just using in the story it it was
important to know that he wasn't funny
and he found out and then he [ __ ]
went crazy but he has his own problems
I I mean it turned into a whole thing I
didn't mean to have really and then I
was like but I would never have I was
like trying to explain it's been like
this specific person is unfunny it was
just for the story to explain it I had
to say this person was unfunny right it
was just an important part of the story
how often do you go on set every week
um usually every night I've been trying
to take some nights off every night and
how much or like Monday Monday sometimes
I take off and then Sundays all new
stuff every time or no I do a lot of
crowd work
um and try to kind of find jokes out of
that
um but I do try to do something new
every night I've been really working on
it I I want to do a new 20 to 30 minutes
by mid-september because I'm starting to
go back to clubs that I went to last
year and I just want to make sure I have
like a fresh set for them and I could do
all crowd work and it could be
completely new but I just want to like
do the work and you know they're coming
to see me and I want to give them the
best shows possible where can people see
you coming up
um when does this come out
um I don't know it could be a couple of
weeks four weeks or so oh okay well you
can go to annieleterman.com shows all my
shows are up there but I'm going to a
bunch of places and it's just so fun the
live shows are where it's at people
gotta come it's so fun I love meeting
everyone doing the meet and greets I do
like a merch meet and greet line and go
see her yeah go see Annie Letterman
let's laugh and heal and feel good about
ourselves and I'm gonna get the
hypnotist's phone oh my God you're gonna
love her I can't wait you're gonna
[ __ ] it's it changes my life I'm
gonna give you ten percent you don't
have to give me anything you're you live
a good life that'll be the ten percent
all right that's all I want to do that's
all we want to do is listen yes and we
just watch people getting stabbed for
some reason but other than that oh on
all these posts I have a theory though I
think this is like a way to disassociate
watching horror yeah because it's not
it's so like the glory or the better
right because no I don't really like too
gory what do you feel about like what
did you think about like The Hills Have
Eyes I didn't like it why
uh I just thought it was boring and it
was just kind of like redundant and just
I I just remember not never liking that
I feel like in horror if the acting's
too good I can't hang I need the
ratatary hereditary was pretty badass
hereditary you gotta see that I would
love to see it with a weird little girl
yeah really scary but I like fun movies
like The Evil Dead I like Lost Boys
vampire all 80s movie yeah um
Return To Living Dead is a silly zombie
movie I don't like this kind of like
saws I mean they're they're sort of
entertaining but I stopped such anxiety
it's just too much for me it's too much
hostile yeah hostile I kind of enjoyed
the first one yeah it was kind of crazy
it was fun I like the whole concept of
it was so cool yeah but um yeah no I
Hills advice like I can't see hardcore
scenes I'm like church
I don't need to see that yeah but I I
mean I understand what they're doing
they're making you feel something very
intensely I'm just like I'm good I don't
want to feel that again I'm hungry are
you hungry
let's eat some brains uh thanks for
being on the podcast it was so fun but
it really was fun it was awesome I felt
like I met a new friend now yes follow
me on Instagram I'm just starting my
Tick Tock too yeah
guys at Annie Letterman leader man yes I
put the man in Letterman that's what he
said I'm asking dude she keeps it real
please
guys you know when I like someone so
there you go
he starts beating me when I leave
you know um funny enough Annie got me
into the hypnotherapy she's the one who
introduced me to the person oh right I
met her on this podcast she started
talking about it and then I I got the
number and I or the email because no one
calls each other anymore and I emailed
this woman Mary Lou and she's been great
and uh we're working on my way of
thinking the way I think uh Thanks for
opening up so much you know a lot of
comedians you know
we're just functional we are
dysfunctional and we've had a lot of
things happen in our lives and talking
about them and making light of
situations however dark they may be
not only helps us but it helps other
people and you when you can make not
make fun but laugh about things that are
tragic or you know and just uh
I don't know there's there's something
about it that that helps and uh she's
very good at that so Annie great great
[ __ ]
um she talked about her podcast and all
that stuff so make sure you listen to
her
and um
that's about all I have to say Ryan
that's it I I don't have much to say
today
um
you know it's been um
it's it's it's it's a year it's you know
the 50th you know my 50th year
it's definitely
midlife crisis [ __ ] probably that I
don't even know about and uh
but uh the support from friends and
family mostly friends and uh my lovable
listeners and patrons and all that
that's it's been very helpful so thank
you guys and uh and I'd like to say that
our Sun spin
sunspin concert we have a concert
October 1st Saturday 2 p.m and 6 p.m
Pacific Standard time we're doing two
shows we haven't played in a while get
your tickets at sunspin.com or go to
stageit.com and type in sunspin and get
tickets and show up and support please I
love you I really with the band The
album's coming out soon and we need you
so get tickets all right it's time to
say all those lovable Patron names top
tier patrons who get back to the podcast
in more ways than one here we go
Nancy D Leah asks Sarah V little Lisa
Yukiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B
Jason W Sophie M Kristen K Raj C Joshua
D cjp Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Kimberly e Mike E Eldon
Supremo 99 more
Santiago am Chad W lien P Maya P Maddie
s Belinda n Chris H Dave H Sheila G Brad
d Ray H Tabitha T Tom and Lillian a
Talia M Betsy D Chad B Marion Dan n big
Stevie W Angel M Rhiannon C correct
Corey K devnex and Michelle a Jeremy C
Andy T gavinator David C John B Brandy D
Camille s the see now the chief there's
also at the C but oh he expanded it oh
he did so it was the C yeah all right
there you go Joey M design OTG Eugene
and Leah Nikki G Corey Katie B Patricia
Heather L Jake B Megan T Mal s Orlando C
Caroline R Christine a s Sarah s Eric H
Shane r
Emma R Jeremy V Andrew M satuichi 77
Oracle Chris R Michael F Karina n
Michelle D Amanda R Amanda s gen B Kevin
e Katie red Stephanie K lena82 and jorel
couldn't do it without you guys I really
appreciate you thanks for listening to
the show I am Michael Rosenbaum from the
Hollywood Hills in California and I'm
Ryan Taz from the Hollywood Hills of
California
the guys be good to yourself
um and we'll see you next week thanks
for uh thanks for watching or listening
whatever you're doing I appreciate it
write a review don't forget see ya
[Music]